i do i cannot tell you the moment when i
actually learn how to play chess
because unfortunately nobody was there
to tweet about it
yeah
it was um
winter
evening 68 69 my parents
uh tried to solve a chess puzzle from a
local newspaper and uh
and i just discovered the the mystery of
this
little wooden chessboard you know you
know 64 square 32 pieces nobody told me
how to move the pieces i learned by just
watching them you know so and and at one
point you know i revealed that i knew
some of the secrets
and um it was match made in heaven so
very quickly you know so they just
recognized that instead of sending me to
a music school because all my parents or
from my father's sides are all these uh
relatives were musicians um that's a
jewish side so um
uh and um and he said no no no it just
you know that's the
that's that's not for gary so he's a
different kind of mind so
so and i was sent to a chess club at age
seven it's sadly it was his last
decision he
uh he died from leukemia it's when i was
seven
and uh for the next 50 years so i was um
under the divine shield of my mother
who sadly passed last christmas you know
from carved and um
and she spent her entire life you know
working for me for your only son and
and
that was the beginning that was the
beginning and very quickly i realized
that chess would be my life
but also i realized that it's not just
about chess and that's another important
lesson from my mother
so yes chess is about winning and losing
of course it's about winning
um
but
it's also about making the difference
and that's that's that was a fundamental
you know
like message to me that i carried
throughout my my entire life and that's
why i could rebuild my life after i left
professional chess in 2005 because it's
it's about making a difference and
that's answer to your first you know
question it's about intensity if i'm in
you know i have to try to make the
difference
maybe not as much as i did in the world
of chess but anywhere so i believe that
we can make a contribution so and that's
the like a motto of my life so let's say
i even had it on the top of my of my bed
she put it when i was 11 or 12. if not
you who else
i mean just don't complain about others
don't complain about weather conditions
this is about you powerful so this is
you can do whatever you want as long as
you're in so when you devote yourself to
again whatever task you've selected gary
how much of the drive was there any you
said your father passed away when you
were seven years old how much drive came
from there to want to make him proud was
there any drive where you're like i'm
gonna go out there and do something big
to leave a legacy for the last name was
there anything there look up absolutely
so it's again this is the fact that my
mother never remarried and she just you
know she she made this big sacrifice you
know um i i knew that i had to i had to
be up to the challenge so look
we still need a little bit of luck you
know with with our professional career
even if you have a talent and you're a
hard worker and by the way it's i always
you know
argue with people who say oh
he or she you know is a great talent
uh or
other way around actually it's not so
talented but has you know is a hard
worker i believe the hard work is also
talent
so again that's another interesting
mother oh so you believe a person who
works hard that is a form of a talent
it's of course a talent you know this is
exactly
look talent is something that is
possessed by few or not everybody and we
know that not everybody is a hard worker
so which means working hard as a talent
and when you combine it with your
natural talent
for chess for
whatever so just whatever field you you
selected so that's that's an explosive
combination so if you like this sort of
short clip from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire interview
and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]